In this project we're using some ordinary
disposable diapers, to create an extraordinary
gardening gel, that's non-toxic, environmentally
friendly, and can cut your watering schedule
in half.
For this project we'll need one of these disposable
diapers. New or gently used, it doesn't really
matter. Now most people know that a diaper
can hold quite a bit of liquid, but you might
be surprised to see how much. I just put over
4 cups of water in this thing, and you can
see that in just a few seconds, all the fluid
is completely absorbed, without a drop left
in the bowl. To see what's inside, let's go
ahead and rip it open, and dump the contents
into a bowl. You can see that if we add a
bit more water and mix it together, we've
got ourselves an amazing, fiber rich hydrogel.
I tried packing some of this stuff into an
airtight bag and freezing it overnight, to
make an improvised ice pack that won't leak.
Now, you can use food coloring to change the
color of the gels, but when working with plants
it's best to leave it clear. This way, your
plants won't turn funny colors as they grow.
One adult sized diaper makes over 12 cups
of hydrogel, and the small pieces of cotton
wadding break apart and mix right in. Now
we're gonna need some all purpose potting
soil that you can get at any home improvement
store, and a large mixing bowl to dump it
in. Add equal parts of dirt and gel, then
begin working the two together until they're
thoroughly mixed. Now you've not got a super
absorbent, super soil that's light and fluffy,
and perfect for your potted plants. Go ahead
and throw a little soil into the pot first,
then help your plant get comfortable. To hold
it firm in place, just keep packing more soil
until everything sits tight. You can finish
up by giving the plant a bit more water, and
now with the super crystals in your soil,
your plant can go twice as long between waterings,
saving you time, and resources. If you're
looking for a lazy way to get your seeds started,
just dump them into a batch of the grow dough,
and give it all a good mix, or you could even
just sprinkle the seeds on top. Fill a container
of your choice, add a bit of water, and find
a place that you can set it and forget it.
Over the course of a week, your seeds will
automatically sprout and begin to grow, without
any extra effort, or any extra water.
In the event of an extreme overwatering like this,
you might expect that your plants would drown,
or begin to rot. But with the hydrogels infused
in the soil, you can see how the excess water
is quickly absorbed, keeping the soil damp
and fluffy, and possibly saving your plants
as a result. Now the reason this mixture will
hold so much liquid is because of these super-absorbent
water crystals. They'll hold over 500 times
their weight in water, and if you want to
separate them out like this, try ripping apart
the wadding in the diaper, and shaking it
upside down over a piece of paper. The cotton
fluff should blow away, and you'll be left
with just the crystals. This diaper gel can
work on your existing plants as well. As the
gel expands and contracts, it will naturally
aerate the soil as it does. Just grab a knife
and a spoon, and gently nestle them down between,the roots, and spread them apart to form a
gap. Now you can drop some gel down to the
roots, work the soil back together, and continue
around the pot until all your water-gel is
used up. For one final idea, you can help
preserve your fresh cut flowers, by adding
sugar, vinegar, and a bit of bleach to some
warm water. This will create a homemade flower
food, and when you add your slush powder,
you'll see it absorbs the solution and slowly
grows up to 60 times its size. By agitating
the gel you can create an awesome effect that
looks like crushed ice. Not only does it look
cool, but it's slowly releasing water as the
flowers need it, and feeding them at the same
time. The gel is completely non-toxic. It's
biodegradable, and environmentally friendly,
so it's a great option for working into your
garden. Not only will this save you on watering
costs, but it will also last quite a few seasons
before it needs to be replaced. Well now you
know how to take an ordinary diaper, and convert
it into a super absorbant potting soil, that
will help keep your plants happy, and hopefully
keep you happy as well. If you liked this
project, perhaps you'll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com